she's getting weaker and time is running
out and yet her chances of beating
leukemia are better than they were the
day she was diagnosed and that's because
Lara's survival is a numbers game and
the odds are starting to swing in her
favor that's why we're now appealing to
anyone especially those in mixed race
his thanks to her firmly who've launched
a campaign to find her a stem cell donor
which in Lara's case is particularly
difficult because of her heritage she's
half Thai half Italian the more people
could join the donation register the
better her chances of finding a match
and with some of the most famous people
in the world suddenly taking an interest
the message has gone global it's all
been so heartening and getting messages
from people that I don't even know who
have told me that they've seen the
campaign and they've gone to sign up is
really wonderful and all the support
just makes this whole process a lot
easier really tell us about when you
when you first got diagnosed what did
they tell you and what was your
understanding of your particular
situation I knew about the possibility
of having to need a transplant and we
were waiting for awhile to find out
whether my brother would be a possible
donor and but unfortunately he's not so
that's why and waiting for a donor who
will be a stranger 26 million people are
on donor registers around the world that
might sound like a lot but it can still
be incredibly difficult to find a match
especially for those of mixed ethnicity
because only 3% are of mixed-race origin
the result is that four out of five from
this group failed to find a perfect
match and that's where Lara's campaign
has been so successful in just over two
weeks eight and a half thousand people
have registered in Britain and half of
those people are from ethnic minorities
or mixed-race backgrounds so you get the
best possible match you need to be from
the same or similar ethnic backgrounds
so if you're from a mixed race like
Laura is half Thai of Italian you need
to find someone with that similar
background so that's just incredibly
difficult all you have to do to register
is provide a saliva sample Lara needs to
find a donor by April and she knows
there's a chance it might not happen but
by encouraging people all over the world
to join the database she and her family
may well have saved the lives of others
in the future
Richard Suchet Sky News